des discussions sont en cours de chaque
côté les administrations s'organise pour
faire coïncider les calendriers on parle
d'une fenêtre possible dès la mi juin
même si officiellement aucune date n'a
encore été arrêtée
effectivement certaines propositions ont
été formulées
je ne peux pas confirmer les dates
d'autant plus qu'aucune date n'a encore
été convenu il s'agit effectivement en
gros des mois d'été mais une fois encore
aucune date n'a été fixée
il reste à analyser de nombreux facteurs
pour parvenir à un accord définitif dans
l'équipe
la reprise du dialogue entre les deux
puissances est plus que nécessaire étant
donné les relations exécrables de ces
dernières semaines de ces derniers mois
sanctions américaines
expulsions croisées de diplomates
affaires navalni aux détentions dans le
donbass même si dans ce dernier dossier
la russie a envoyé un signal
d'apaisement en annonçant la fin des
exercices militaires et donc le retrait
des troupes de l'ouest et du sud du pays
malgré tout moscou tient toujours
washington pour responsables de la
détérioration de leurs relations
la diplomatie russe a d'ailleurs fait
savoir qu'une liste de pays hostiles à
la russie était en préparation
et apparemment les états unis en feront
partie
la liste est en train d'être rédigée
forcément ce décret du gouvernement et
préparer au format interministériel
comme vous le comprenez et je peux le
confirmer
les etats unis d'amérique figurent sur
la liste évidemment vous découvrirez les
noms des autres états quand ce décret du
gouvernement sera publié et la liste en
question verra donc le jour
l'annoncé d'une rencontre entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine est forcément
une bonne nouvelle mais il faudra
probablement davantage qu'une simple
rencontre en face à face pour normaliser
les relations entre les deux pays tant
ses relations sont dégradées à l'heure
actuelle